okay we got Lair Lemire
so here here's this question We'll add
them to the stream and we'll start with
this question first so can you give me a
little bit of background behind this
hi Rich it's uh honor uh you're just a a
great inspiration uh especially to all
of us in the United States
um basically I live in South Florida and
I have uh repeatedly let down my boss
it's my first professional job I've had
I don't have a college background it's
uh uh something I kind of lucked into uh
just an assistant role and a just
constant
constant screw-ups and uh
it's starting to really affect my
reputation not just here at my job but
also locally in Southwest what kind of
Scrubs are we talking about here like
like what are we doing wrong uh yeah
behavioral behavioral screw-ups okay
yeah
lateness tardiness errors so
okay so lateness tardiness and errors
are character traits and
I mean if you want to reinvent yourself
why can't you reinvent yourself with the
existing company and show up in time and
not make the errors and stuff like that
uh some of them are really severe uh did
they terminate you do they discipline
you like what do they do as a
consequence of them
uh well being passed over for promotion
uh basically is the punishment it's kind
of uh
uh also shame too yeah and
like something as simple as being on
time like why like why are you showing
up like
uh yeah this is kind of like a following
up on your video you did a while ago
about the friend you had uh with
problems like I have uh
like vices
um habitual problems
uh tried going to group to uh get over
it and uh what kind of vices we're
talking like alcohol drugs we you know
uh no uh
like adult material online okay yeah so
you're showing up late to work because
of porn
yeah nervousness and that pretty much
yes sir yeah well look man I mean
this is gonna follow you wherever you go
you know until you deal with this this
this
um like
as somebody that's been an employer uh
you know whether I was an employee at a
company as a manager or
when I was running my own company as an
entrepreneur
um tardiness to me is disrespectful like
um
whenever I set a time like I'm you guys
probably noticed if you've watched me
for a while I I almost always kick off
my show when it's scheduled for right
and if I can't kick off my show for the
schedule time I usually pull you push it
back like you know 10 or 15 minutes and
it might be because my guess is late or
my computer's [__] up and I gotta
reboot or something like that but
uh like I learned this lesson as a young
man because
and I'll tell you the story
um I didn't have any respect for my
dad's time and we used to go to the mall
when I was in elementary school and he
would go get the groceries and he said
you know I'll be done in 25 minutes meet
me here at the exit in 25 minutes and I
would go down to the arcade and I play
video games
um and one time you know I don't know I
was probably doing well in the video
game and I didn't want to lose my score
and I kept playing and I was late and I
made my Dad wait like two minutes and he
was pissed he said to me look
you don't respect my time when you show
up late
in future there's going to be a penalty
if you're ever late again I'm going to
charge you 25 cents for every whatever
it was like 30 seconds or a minute or
something like that and I I thought to
myself okay fine you know whatever next
time that I was late he charged me I was
I was never late again after that
because there was a financial penalty
you know there's a consequence to that
and that was over a video game like
video games are just as addictive as
anything else right look there's a
reason why we sit in front of our
screens doing this [__] for [__]
hours at a time you know getting to the
next level because we're addicted to
that [__] because it draws you in it's
like oh I can level up I can get better
armor I can get more whatever and it's
like you know this whole path to
leveling up in a pretend world when we
should be leveling up in real life and
when you come to the realization that
you should be leveling up in real life
and that's more important than the
pretend world or some make-believe [__]
that's going on in your head then you
take real life seriously
I don't know what to tell you man it's
like it's like one of those like these
are basic fundamental concepts that I
think high value men need to understand
and even if you're not a high value man
if you want to improve your life like
your question is how do I reinvent
myself from being a loser without
changing where I live
like changing where you live still still
doing still adopting and behaving and
luxurious you know sort of ways is going
to be the same thing if you do it in
California New York Chicago
Florida it doesn't matter you know
you're still going to do the same stuff
you have to change your belief system
change in the outside world starts from
a belief system belief systems govern
the choices that we make when we make
those choices we get results as a as a
as a consequence of those choices a
simple game that you can play when you
go to the grocery store when you're in
the checkout line and you see what
people take out of their buggy and they
put on the conveyor belt and they buy is
take a look at what they look like and
then see what's on the conveyor belt
that they're buying
there's always a direct correlation
between the choice that they make when
they walk through the store and put that
stuff from the buggy on the conveyor
belt and they take it home and they put
it in their face and they eat it right I
go through the exact same store that
they do
but I look like this at my age rather
than what they look like at their age
which is usually younger than me and it
looks like [__] so
it's it's it's beliefs that I hold for
myself for the kind of man that I want
to be the kind of life that I want to
live the kind of
uh impression that I want to leave you
guys with what I'm all about when people
see me in real life and they come up to
me they're you know I am who I am and
they and they recognize me and I'm
acknowledged for that and that's not
important because I want to impress
people that's important for me because
that's who I am that is that is part of
my belief I don't believe that it is
acceptable to be out of shape to be
incompetent to be slouchy to be dressed
poorly to walk around with clothes with
spaghetti stains or something like that
on it I I have certain standards and
certain beliefs and if you want to get
better results like if you want to
reinvent yourself
the simple answer to that is raise your
standards
yes sir right
once you raise your standards you're
going to have a different set of beliefs
that you're going to hold yourself and
you're going to make different choices
you're going to prioritize well my shift
starts at eight
I'm there at eight or I'm there before
eight I'm there you know well before
eight or whatever it happens to be
because that's your priority because
you've raised your standards now
does that make sense yes it does yes it
does that's where I would start my man
thank you rich thank you all right buddy
take care
I really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clips from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out